ils sont au moins 303 son gilet jaune
sur ce rond point devenu le symbole de
la contestation à la sortie de vesoul
pendant ce temps d'autres gilets sont en
pleine collecte les gilets orange cette
fois la banque alimentaire qui dans les
grandes surfaces récolte de la
nourriture pour aider des familles tout
au long de l'année
gilet jaune et gilet orange se sont
entendus pour l'occasion les gilets
jaunes je pense tous solidaires et donc
nous laisse passer et donc cette année
on a quand même apporté un plus on a
fait des bacs et donc aux prises
endommagé une nous laisse passer un
dialogue constructif avec les gilet
jaune
c'est ce que souhaite également les
commerçants qui pour certains on se
retrouve en difficulté face à ce
mouvement
pascal ferrari vice présidente de la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie de
haute saône a organisé avec d'autres une
réunion hier soir dans ce sens
gilet jaune et commerçants réunis pour
échanger
c'était dans le plus grand respect de
chacun c'était surtout de mettre en
avant les problématiques de nos de nos
commerçants notamment de nos petits
commerçants nos commerçants qui sont sur
les points de blocage aussi où là on a
on se dirige vers des catastrophes
économiques puisque aujourd'hui on a
quelques quelques commerçants au
rond-point de noidans qui vont devoir
lancer des procédures de chômage
technique
un dialogue un lien avant qu'il ne soit
trop tard pour certains petits commerces
dans le centre de vesoul
les commerçants ont tenté une autre
approche face à ce mouvement
le message qu'on a voulu faire passer
c'est bien peu importe que mon habillé
en jean en robe ou en gilet jaune venez
venez nous voir nous on est prêt les
commerçants on à la porte on à n'importe
qui est grande ouverte
des gilets jaunes conscient du problème
des petits commerces c'est ce qu'il nous
répète sur le terrain au quotidien leur
unique souhait que le président de la
république les entende une bonne fois
pour toutes
[Musique]